listen ladies when you guys have decided
like what you like and don't like could
you please like write a manifesto for
the guys and we can like just read it
you know okay because the contradictions
are endless now yeah no because i mean
you got to read rollo tomassi's book he
talks about it it's like women have a
need for security so the beta side but
we also are attracted to the alpha side
so it's like women have five baiting
strategies and one is we want a guy
that's gonna stay so i meet you and i
think he's gonna stick around for the
kids two a woman a guy's going to stay
and take care of the kids so and
financially he can he's competent enough
to money um good gene so tall
good-looking um legacy so he's not going
to embarrass the family and
god i always forget the fifth one
but um
good genes and i want to say it's
something with oh social status that's
the fact right and so but the alpha side
is more like the guy that doesn't take
[ __ ] he's kind of an [ __ ] but we're
still attracted to the beta side but it
also depends where we are in our cycle
um which one we're attracted to ain't
nobody got time for all this i know
that's right
that's the life of a woman yeah and so
you think you think it's hard for you
and where we are in life too because
that's why a girl like when she's
younger she'll date the bad boys
because they have more of the alpha
alpha need but when she gets closer to
having the kids then she's trying to
find someone to actually stick around
and help her take care of them the beta
seat so but that's that's why like the
single mother like single mothers are
fulfilling both mating strategies
because what they'll do is they'll get
the kid from the alpha and then they'll
find the beta to take care of them i
think so it's like do you see why i tell
men to just not listen to women i think
they think like seriously that's telling
you how it is no because i'm giving you
facts no you don't believe me you're
giving you're giving us facts yeah but
what man has got time to be like okay i
can't be this and i can't be there but i
can't be too much there then i can't be
too much that but i can do that and we
ain't got time for that the thing i'm
sorry
is i think most women would agree with
that those five things i think most men
would as well
but also
those five things and the kind of
level of
the guys that have all five of the five
five of those things is small and it's
the upper echelon and they're more
likely to cheat and if they're not more
likely to cheat they're more likely
probably to turn to corn no exactly like
you're 100 right it's a very small
percentage but but that's why that's why
women
it's like you pick and choose what you
can get but you see girls around like 27
to 12 like 30 switch what they go for
because they have to prioritize the beta
need because they need someone to make
kids with because their biological clock
is ticking so a woman wants a beta alpha
essentially a happy medium yeah that's
what but they don't they don't the
problem is they don't really exist
[Laughter]
the need to be right is strong in this
room
just want to pick up my babes because
your bit both yeah who tried this guy
so you so you found your beta alpha
but basically
would you describe himself as a beta
alpha no we don't we don't use these
terms in the house this is you're just
you're just that guy you've got a
perfect amount of
and a perfect amount of
would he still be what you said if he
was watching corn behind your
back yes of course
yes it'll still be the same thing
at what um
age
were people introduced to corn
oh wow
that guy scarred me at 19. 19. or 20 19
or 20. i don't remember i don't remember
how i got introduced to it yeah honestly
definitely it must have been page free
yeah it must have been and then you just
kind of randomly type in stuff on google
a lot of the websites you can't get on
or wasn't it like looking up yeah
looking at the top shelf yeah top shelf
yeah i'd talk about yourself in the news
agency i think that was probably my 10
or 11 for me yeah i think i was about 13
yeah my friend i went to my from
specific room i went to my friend's
house
and i think he was like 15
and he was like guys there was a bunch
of guys and he was like guys look i've
got this vhs time right
is that i've got this video on my mom
that's my mom's video i'm not supposed
to watch it and i was like really he was
like yeah yeah and i was like we were
like what is it because we were like 13
like what is it and he put it on and it
was
like being like a 13 14 year old boy and
seeing that it literally just blew your
mind you're like i didn't know people
done this yeah exactly
do you know what i mean so i'm just like
maybe i was it you said the average age
is what 11 11 yeah and i was like 13. i
don't know but i think people are
introduced
to corn quite early now especially
children yeah
so for me i i had easy access to corn um
apart from the page freezing shell
somewhat right
and fall asleep
and i'd get home from yeah it would be
on and i'd get home from school and i'd
be like and i i remember finding the
tape and i'm like okay i'm gonna make
i'm gonna make a mental note of where
this tape
is gonna go and i'll retrieve it when
he's asleep or whatever and we're
talking calling back in the day we're
five hours long
so wait five hours
yeah
the corn he had what what were they
doing in the video this is different it
was different for everything yeah
different things
literally so i would just sit there for
hours watching it over and over and over
again when everybody was asleep i put it
on before school i put it on did anyone
ever catch you no no no he caught me
once
he
so he didn't catch me watching anyway he
caught the aftermath because i would use
um i don't know why but i would use his
t-shirt to clean up after what well you
use his t-shirt yeah
it was just the first thing i found it
wasn't armani as well
it was the first thing i found so
[Laughter]
um so yeah so he he he grilled me if it
was me and i denied it to the grave so i
hope he never sees that how do you say
um 10 10 or 11.
10 and you were you were you were
jerking off at 10. yeah
watching full feature limps i think i
think this has a con like a correlation
to where you are now
100 perhaps yeah i guess so
mm-hmm
but like it's cool i can i can control
it it's not like it's not it's not like
blind but every every new year seven
group that came into the high schools
previously working in
they were
age 11 to 12. yeah i was horrified when
i first started working there
the amount of explicit yeah
not even just what was on their phones
but just what would come out of their
mouths what they would be wanting to do
with their their girlfriend or what
they've done with this girl what they
haven't done and i'll be like
shut up yeah shut up you haven't made
your bed
we've got cheese stuck around it just
please stop yeah i can imagine what corn
is like in this channel if it was if for
when it was hard for me it was that
accessible i can imagine what it's like
now the internet is scary
you know what's crazy it shrinks your
brain
yeah um
a 2014 study in the journal jma
psychiatry um found men who can
regularly consumed corn had smaller
brain volume and fewer connections in
this strat time
a brain region tied to reward processing
compared with those who didn't view corn
however it's possible um the brain
region shrinks simply because people
become accustomed to viewing viewing
pornographic images and thus find them
less rewarding
yeah right
um she's trying to say you've got a
small brain i don't know no i don't know
the smallest in the room
um
so it says a new research from the
security technology company has reported
that children under the age of 10 now
account for 22 percent of online
jesus so
so under the age of 10. yeah so how how
crazy though is it when you think about
it like tick tock movies like there's so
much stuff that has soft core corn yeah
that we're not protecting like kids
against because but even what we call
soft porn corn
stuffed corn yeah
um
today
would have been wild say
30 years ago or 50 years ago 15 years
ago even yeah yeah and it's it's just
really how how far are we going with
this desensitization
especially for children it's just so
dangerous
so do you